murat the earlier ruling involved as i
say huge sums of money what's the
situation now
well when they originally made the
judgment in favor of gmt limited which
is
the representative of the shareholders
of ucos it was at the time the biggest
arbitration ruling
in history now this sega which began 15
years ago this is just the latest twist
the dutch supreme court has now ruled
that uh perhaps russia does have the
right to appeal uh the verdict that's
ruling that it should pay 57 billion to
former ucos investors because they may
well have committed fraud that is in its
its latest ruling uh now the case will
go back to a lower chamber of court and
they will review everything again but
previously we had seen much shareholders
celebrating while the russian state said
that this ruling is simply unfair now
we've heard from the latest russian
reaction uh that they hope the dutch uh
the dutch court and dutch judges will
rule in favor of russian taxpayers
russia insists that there was uh that
there was no raid or sort of ill intent
when it seized you cos
and when you cost assets were sold off
when it was faced with huge taxes which
russia says for many years it it refused
to pay but undoubtedly there will be
more twists and turns in this uh you
cost story in the years to come
yeah big development though miraculous
day of our senior correspondent taking
us through that thanks moran
you